amy is with us in Michigan hi Amy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
it's an honor to speak with you thank
you for taking my call sure so I know
that I am a single mom with three
children and I know I have to write to
file for child support on my
ex-boyfriend but I just want to know if
it is the moral thing to do or the godly
thing to do in this situation
I have never file for child support I've
had children with him for five and a
half years and he has never paid except
for maybe like six payments just in cash
just random payments but he's never
other than about six payments of a
couple hundred dollars he's never paid
me anything for the children and I'm
hesitant and filing support on him
because number one he's an undocumented
immigrant so I'm afraid he will get in
trouble or he'll get found out and get
in trouble with ice for working under a
false identity I'm not sure that he so
does but I I know he has a job and so he
may still be working under a false name
and then the other reason I'm scared
about filing for support on him is just
the fact that I kind of told him to get
out of my children's in my life because
he's highly emotionally abusive and so I
kind of feel like how this is just not
right for me to file for support if I
basically told him to eggs in our lives
and and the third thing the reason that
I'm hesitant and asking for support from
the from him is that when I wanted to
add have a sibling for my for our
daughter we were you know I told them
you know will you please help me on to
have a sibling for our daughter and he's
like well sure but you know I can't pay
for that right and because I can't even
pay for our daughter so you know I'm not
going to pay anything and so I'll help
you as long as you're cool with me not
paying anything and I was like oh
absolutely that's totally fine don't
worry about it I'll take care of it well
that was back when my income was really
good but I'm a little broke now and
basically having to take out loans to
get groceries and things like that
and so I'm just like what do I do but I
don't want to do the wrong thing just
because I can't get groceries either
so I just need your advice well the
there's so much going on here the number
kit number one stop having children with
people who don't support them and that
you're not married and that you're not
married to okay you didn't ask my advice
if you didn't want it but you need to
stop doing that
okay because you got yourself into a
mess obviously right and this is a bad
dude okay he's here illegally
he's an abusive dude and you told him to
stay away and I don't even want to know
the details you told him you want to
have another kid
but you'd pay for it right right okay so
I it sounds like it's more hassle than
it's worth it sounds like you I mean
certainly for one of them you would be
you told him not you wouldn't charge him
right right yeah but you have a deal on
that you have to keep your word on that
I guess keeping your word comes into
this discussion and but I mean here's
the thing what we need to be what we
need to be concerned about is what is
best for the children and what's best
for the children is is for you to get a
career that's going and him to not be
around right right yeah so I think it's
just the fact that things are tight is
the only reason you're considering this
and it's making you try to look past
some of all the these are the negatives
that you did list out very thoroughly so
you got a pretty long list of negatives
down the list on reasons to not do this
mm-hmm 99% of time someone calls up with
this actually when I saw on the screen
file for child support question
hey mark that's not what's on my screen
waiting on you know you to come up I
immediately go well of course I had kids
you got to pay for the kids you know
it's kinda basic basic ethics basic
morality right you ought to take care of
your own dadgum children but this is not
a guy who takes care of anybody right
exactly
he's a taker not a giver and so and
you've got to commit in your life for
the sake of your current three children
to not let this pattern continue in your
life right yes definitely okay all right
so yeah you do that and you work on your
career and your character and you grow
and you take care of these kids because
number one you probably don't gain money
out of him either that's the other
negative on the list because as soon as
they come to try to take money from him
at work he's gone
I mean you're not you're not gonna find
this guy he's gonna be a ghost and I in
you know as soon as he appears he's
gonna disappear and and it would you
know now it's it's not worth it
there's too much negative and almost no
positive to going after him for this the
thing you do is you learn the negative
things that got you into this situation
and you don't replicate those you don't
continue in those patterns and then you
do some things in your personal life to
get your income up to be able to take
care of these kids may include moving
near family it may include whatever to
get some support around you to cause it
to happen sorry I wish I had a better
answer but it is a complicated question